what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm your host morning
Thompson but today I have two other
houses with me we have Wendy from the
movie couple and Chris what's the Osmond
culture you can check both of them out
we'll put their links down below you
should know both of them and they're
going to be on the channel a lot more so
get familiar with them and I'm glad
they're here today because we're talking
about some controversial topics but
we're talking about kind of Marvel phase
for how it was and going into phase five
and DC the DCU the complete reboot of
the DCU which Wendy you and I were
talking and you're like people are
pissed off yeah and we've seen a lot of
people I feel like I've seen both but I
think let's just go ahead and talk about
this first
I think it's a good thing I'm stoked I
think Chris thinks it's good Chris Chris
is first in line for this I've been
saying this for years
I've been saying yeah right
for years you've been saying this
literally he has yeah
I've literally been saying this probably
since
the news of the Batman I think right
because there was like a whole separate
Universe thing I mean I can go back in
my channel and find it but it's been at
least three years I've been saying this
literally it's just there there's no
hope and I can you want to spill about
DC I would probably make this 20 Minute
Podcast turn up to six hours but I won't
but six hours later Chris is still on
you know you guys have gone to bed and
I'm still sitting here ranting about it
it's so that's the only way nobody in
the world could convince me there is
another way for DC to get on its feet
than to say you know what we did a thing
it wasn't the best thing
thanks
let's go yeah what if Henry Cavill
showed up and was like all right Chris
let me convince you yeah
not Henry Cavill changed my mind my mind
could not be changed
it doesn't work okay
I I think
I think you're I agree with you but
let's hear what Wendy has to say first
too
I mean what do you think after that
she's like I'm afraid to I am an island
no no I I do think it's a good thing I
do think it's a good thing I think it's
necessary because of what it seems like
they want to do what you know zazzloff
with his 10-year plan and the hiring of
Jane's gun and Peter saffron I I think
they're trying to build out a more
cohesive universe that can expand out to
the different Earths and they can maybe
eventually build up to that big Ensemble
movie where we have crisis on infinite
earth right
um so but the problem was everybody won
that from day one because we have seen
CW do it and everybody and it's already
in the comics so everybody wants that
day one it's like but we can't get that
until we establish all these characters
for us to fall in love and connect with
them which I thought we really had
something was going you know with
Justice League and I was like okay but
then there's all this like drama and
then we got the Snyder cup which I like
thoroughly enjoyed it was way better the
original version
they're not gonna do anything with it
that's the that's the problem so you
know
so it it's I think resetting it is going
to be a a good thing uh what I was
telling Warren about and I think Chrissy
weren't in here yeah we were just trying
to talk but then I was like I'll save it
for the show is that if you go on
Twitter right now there's a lot of you
know very like mean not mean but there's
no it's me it's it's me people want
James guns they want people things
there's a petition to fire him but this
is where I'll jump in and I'll say it's
doing worse the you know that sucks
they're saying worse things they
couldn't have picked a more perfect
person to be James Gunn than James Gunn
like they're the duo I don't know how I
feel about the duo co-leadership role
but Peter Safran is is pretty
traditionally a quiet back you don't
really hear a lot from him James Gunn is
on Twitter tweeting at that Noob kid69
saying you're wrong and an idiot you
know and and that's perfect yeah and and
he already like that and he's already
started doing that and he's tweeted so
many things about you know yeah we're
starting over and I've talked to all
these actors and the actors have come
out and they've said really good
positive things and you're gonna get
updates in January we know you know I'm
already writing a Superman's quip we
know and any questions that are out
there like he's out there telling these
big scoopers you're an idiot you don't
know anything or yeah no you're right
and it's giving us a direction it's
giving us an idea so James Gunn is the
perfect guy for this and then on top of
that all these people who are all angry
because oh I really loved Henry Cavill I
really liked Aquaman as Jason Momoa
he doesn't care like he just doesn't
yeah he already said like I know we're
gonna piss people off he likes it right
well I think to me it's all about look
he has a vision and I think in his mind
he's like there's only one way this
works and it's to start over to wipe the
Slate clean now he did say like not
everyone's gonna be recast but I think
it's like people like his wife right who
who play roles in the suicide squad and
Peacemaker like characters like that
right
Amanda Waller maybe she stays someone
like that but all like the big
superheroes I think are gonna be recast
And even Chris you and I were talking
about this last night you know Zachary
Levi came out and like responded to
somebody was like oh don't believe
everything you hear we're Gucci I'm
Gucci you know to me I'm like he's just
saying Shazam 2 isn't canceled I'm
pretty sure he's gone after Shazam too
well and then to that note too like
these movies are still coming out right
just like what you're saying well that's
what I'm saying and they don't want the
hype to disappear right exactly you're
not going to say like yep nope they're
gone so it's coming out but who cares
right why would I go watch Shazam too
like you you can't really say you still
have to be strategic as like a business
person right you still have to bring
money to the studio so they're going to
cancel these movies like The Flash and
everything like that I actually think
they should have pushed the flashback
re-written it a little bit and like
that's how you have the complete reset
of the DCU yeah right and then you just
go to a different you just go into a
different Universe from there yeah I
think that would have been good and who
knows like what their actual plan maybe
they maybe they do
they're right exactly maybe maybe they
just who knows but Wendy like you said I
think the idea is to eventually have a
big Multiverse but I think James Gunn
having worked with Kevin feigen at
Marvel a lot I think he realizes that
I'm sorry just the dceu started off
terribly
they just rushed it and they're like
well Marvel spent some time building you
know individual movies introducing
individual characters let's just throw
them all into one it's like
there's no reason for me to invest
besides the fact that it's the Justice
League but that doesn't make it good no
motion
right exactly like I was invested in
Captain America meeting Iron Man because
I had watched both of them falling in
love with both of them as characters as
movies and Thor and you know Black Widow
everyone it's like oh my gosh they're
coming together finally there was no
build up to that it was just kind of
like Oh look The Justice League here you
go
and Wonder Woman and Batman and Superman
had already kind of met each other
before and Batman vs Superman which
was cool I actually did like how Wonder
Woman came into that how they were
introduced but I feel like they just
dropped the ball with everything else
yeah and they do need to reset I
actually
it's sad because I like the casting for
everybody me too that's I think that's
the hardest part and I think that's
where all the The Passion of the fans
coming in like with all the online you
know messages and stuff like that is
like most people really enjoy myself
included really enjoy Henry Cavill as
Superman so I'm like sad for him that
he's not gonna get to you know throw on
the cape and continue as of right now
um I'm still a little pissed that we'd
never got a man of steel two but instead
we got Batman v Superman like I would
have been way more content if we got
mos2 and then we got BBS you know like
Henry Cavill if you really think about
it he had one solo movie as Superman he
really had no time to tell that story at
all well I mean to build on that though
cyborg didn't even get a solo movie The
Flash hasn't happened like they had
justice league and Man of Steel come out
and exactly so it wasn't any of the
actors fault I mean from Aflac to Cavill
to even Zachary Levi like they played
the characters very well the rock is a
fantastic Black Adam but the management
around them there was no James Gunn and
Peter saffron and no plan it was just
hey what movie's gonna make us the most
money next week let's do that and it's
unfortunate but I don't think there is a
situation where you can rewrite that
unless you're doing the whole Multiverse
thing five years plus from now to keep
that guys well right but it gets there
well and that's the whole point is you
have to do it in the future because
otherwise it gets convoluted CEOs right
you have to ha and and what you said was
pert like they didn't have any Vision
that was the problem and their plan kept
changing and it doesn't help that like
the problem with the Snyder verse was
was it like DC Warner Brothers hated it
right they hated it but they saw it as a
they saw it as an opportunity to make
money like let's just be honest right
give the fans what they want but hey we
can make money off of this because
people will watch it we can sell a
version of it put it on HBO Max like
it made sense to do it but they were
done after that there I don't think
there was a world where DC was like
let's bring back in Zack Snyder to do
everything right and let's restore the
snyderburst like that's just what like a
certain group of fans wanted which I get
them right I'm not saying they're wrong
but DC wasn't going to do it Warner Bros
wasn't going to do that right because if
you're in the studio you'll figure out a
way to make money but you're not gonna
like so-called cave in to like demands
of like a select group of people but
James Gunn coming in is kind of that's
his attitude he's he's seen what
Marvel's done he's worked with Marvel
he's seen the connectivity he's seen how
it's supposed to work and I think that's
what he's going to do he's going to
start building these movies it seems
like he's gonna like take these
characters from when they're younger
because he's already said that about
Superman and then build them up and then
in the future we can do the crisis event
so it's almost like there's a blueprint
you could follow that does this already
yeah just have to be patient I think
there was just too many cooks in the
kitchen honestly because babe that's a
big IP and a big money maker and it's
got a built-in fan base so they think
it's you know like let's just put out
movies and it's like the fans want
people watch these characters so much
yeah exactly like yeah you know I I
probably didn't even need to have seen
like a trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 and
I would have just bought a ticket to see
it because I like it you would have
watched it right I would have watched it
yeah didn't love it didn't love it yeah
well and that's the cool thing about
James Gunn is he he has he has enough
money he's done enough like he's doing
this because he's a fan right I I think
he's perfect for it and I I agree with
him
started over I so like it is love hate
because I would love for Cavill to
remain Superman right I would love for
God to remain Wonder Woman but I think
at this point if you try to like mix a
new universe with the kind of the past
it just gets too confusing I don't think
there's a scenario where you can blend
the what the DC EU was with it the new
DCU I don't think there's a scenario
where it's not confusing so I think just
clean slate I'll even bring it one
further than that I think those
characters are those actors and
character combos are tired
you know you have these actors who
genuinely loved the characters cavil
loves Superman he said it several times
he didn't leave he was pushed out and
tried to come back and tried to come
back finally did got pushed out again
you know Wonder Woman gal loves Wonder
Woman Patty Jenkins the creator of all
these movies they're absolutely obsessed
with these characters how excited Jason
Momoa is because we all know he's going
to be playing Lobo like
but after constantly trying to
you know keep this franchise up I just
think it's like you see a Galaga dog
you're just like yeah but what does it
matter you know you see Henry Cavill the
association of the characters is a bad
taste
because of the lack of success in the
Cinematic Universe side of it not with
the actor to the character and I think
you do need to clean that up
right yeah no I I see what you're saying
just kind of it's just kind of the taste
of how Warner Brothers handled it all
and I feel for all of those actors Henry
oh for sure Dwayne I know they're all I
feel really bad for all of them Dwayne
put 12 years into Black Adam you know
and the dude tried he tried even further
than a lot of the actors to put DC on
his back he's like right I'll be Kevin
feige let's go I got phase one I'm just
gonna say it's phase one right like and
you wanted he got shut down
what I did what I am liking is and you
guys already touched on this is that
um you know we're not hearing it from
like some sort of leak that this had
happened to Henry Cavill or this habit
of Dwayne like we're reading it directly
from their personal Instagram accounts
so it's their words their voice and not
you know not
um
coming from somebody else and I think
it's important to let the actors who
have played these characters to make
that announcement with James Gunn
following up on Twitter or his own
Instagram or whatever and saying yup
this is what's happening and then
announcing things like you know we're
gonna We I'm writing a Superman script
and instead of younger but it's not an
origin story because my God we do not
need another Superman or like we all
know at this point if you don't know the
origin story of Batman
or something like that I do want to ask
you guys this though go ahead because
we're talking about
hopefully this new this reset will give
us a cohesive I wonder if you're about
to ask what I was just about to ask go
ahead potentially
what are
the movies such as the Batman Matt
Reeves that's why it's Joker one and two
like how is that going to fit in or are
we placing those on Earth other Earths
or they're like elseworld there's been
close to like no even scooper
information on what's going on with
Batman I've seen a couple of random
Twitter accounts be like Robert
Pattinson's gonna be the new Batman I
think Joker's no its own thing they're
making a second they're gone like a
musical route with it I'm not even sure
how I feel about what they're doing with
that it's gonna be weird
um but I think there's a possibility
that the Batman could be our Batman
there's a possibility it really depends
on how much James Gunn wants to create
his own Batman I think if he's like you
know what it was good people liked it
he's young he loves the Batman
sure let's just skip that step but if he
wants to create his own Batman as James
Gunn this is my Batman then now he's
gonna hack that too and he's gonna
completely start over
I don't think that's a bad idea which
one I actually don't think it's about it
to have Robert Pattinson being the main
Batman I don't know what the universe is
just have that be the main Universe
because if you think about it that kind
of is started from scratch yes you're
too bad you got a little jump start
right that that is yeah you're like you
said Winnie you're too Batman and
yeah just link everything else after
that and it's pretty easy to say like
look yeah look guys we're finishing
Shazam two we're finishing the Flash
and then we're taking it to the Batman
Universe
yeah I mean I'm so excited
bye
I would like them to do but I do think
we're still gonna get the one-off ones
like Joker two and if Batman but here's
the thing is like they had plans for
spin-offs of that Batman Universe like
the penguin stuff like that stuff like
right so so it's like our
we having two universes here like but I
get the idea of doing one-off things but
then when you do a one-off thing of
another one up thing it does become its
own universe so it's like
I think the confusion
is the is the biggest enemy of DC
is nobody ever had an idea what the
clear picture was what exists and what
and I think they have to get rid of that
so I would be all for them just making
that Universe the main universe and then
you know that's your two Batman get your
your one Superman get your year one one
more one Wonder Woman and I think enough
people like them to do that like Robert
Pattinson did a great job oh I love him
everybody involved with that Batman it
was fantastic it's a young Batman which
is what we're trying to go with here it
sounds like so that's definitely a great
direction to take it and then of course
James Gunn's already come out and said
like there's gonna be video games that
are Canon there's going to be TV shows
so all those spin-off shows if they're
like you know what yeah this is the new
Gotham this is everything that happens
here is new Batman Canon new DCU Canon
go you know then there's zero problem
with that it's gonna be if it's shouted
a mystery and we're sitting here trying
to guess
is this Batman our Batman he needs to be
like yes you know what guys January the
7th we have a big DC announcement guys
Robert Pattinson your DC you Batman
everybody clap your hands that'd be
great
but if not then then you'd be like yeah
no they're doing a Trilogy and then he's
done
one way or the other I need I just need
yeah I do think they need to wrap that
up somehow yeah if they're if that's not
going to be the main route they go they
should wrap it up and make it very clear
like like you said we're doing this and
then and then it's all about that's what
they need to do they need to make it all
about One Universe because you know what
we're about to die and this will lead us
into Marvel we're about to dive into
like the true Multiverse
in Phase five
nothing's really done that yet
right there hasn't really been a
Cinematic Universe that's had the
Multiverse in it so to end on DC I don't
think you can just go straight into the
Multiverse because it's too confusing at
this point in time I need Marble's doing
a really good job they're easing us into
it like with Doctor Strange they talked
about the incursions and stuff like that
and you know ant-man's going to
introduce us a little bit more to
variants and stuff like that
Spider-Man apart from home did it as
well no way home sorry Spiderman no way
home did that and
there is an essential and that's what
Marvel did right they eased us into the
whole Cinematic Universe but it took
years exactly and DC wanted to do it in
like two films yeah start which is
Justice League start with Justice League
people know who Superman is start with
Justice League right and I get the
thinking it's like everyone knows who
the Justice League is but it's like I
still want to have a connection with
those characters with those actors right
it's the connections the emotion it's
the feeling and to be honest like
we didn't talk about this stuff every
day but the vast majority of the
population does not right let's just be
honest so but anyways moving on to uh
well let us know let us know if you're
happy down below about a complete swipe
of the DC Universe just starting from
fresh that's what they're doing break
yourself on a scale of Chris to Wendy
crystalline are you Chris are you a
Warren are you a Wendy but we all agree
that we want the resources
that means everybody should agree
everyone should agree so everybody 10
out of 10. but
so Marvel like I said about the
Multiverse the Multiverse is coming like
the true Multiverse is coming now what
we got Doctor Strange because that was
kind of all that down but
phase four was kind of that building
phase
right wouldn't you all agree
oh yeah
we've always knew that so yeah and phase
four was yeah received in many different
ways by many different people I would
say
maybe like right down the middle but I
did the video that was talking about
Kevin feige wasn't happy with phase four
and they're they're gonna focus on
quality over quantity now and the
comments in that video were all like yes
that needs to happen less like they did
so much in Disney plus they did so much
well we can just it was too much it
honestly was just that now though like
do you both just agree there was too
much coming out in two years
yes I do it was a lot it was a lot and I
think they were trying to to wrap up
some stuff and to also move us into the
next phase and also at the same time
introduce a couple of characters that's
going to play into it like Sean Chi so
everything they did in the infinity Saga
all the projects they did they almost
did
the same amount of projects in like a
year in like two years that's a lot it's
too much it's not it's not special it's
not important it's just next project
next project there's no digestive time
they're just drowning Us in content and
I get they're trying to promote Disney
plus whoever they is whether it was you
know if it's Kevin if it's Bob it's
relevant as the consumer totally JPEG
and I think it's safe to say all of us
here are super fans I mean
sure right it's too much it's too much
and for the Layman fan for the Casual
fan
or the new off starting fast just where
do you even begin
it's just too much
so now face five
is really supposed to bring us in it and
we have some
really great projects coming to Face by
starting with Ant-Man of the WASP
quantumania which is where I really
think we're gonna dive into the whole
Multiverse aspect of it for sure because
there's going to be more than one king
in it right and ant-man's going to be
speaking with Kang kind of about
other kings right and we get Loki season
two and I mean this is really about to
open it up so do we think
I I think it's a no-brainer but do we
think phase five is just gonna be so
much better than phase four no
no I don't I don't think it's gonna be
the problem is and the problem will
always be we're comparing it to end game
we're not comparing it to phase one like
if you compare phase four to phase one
they're similarly good I mean they're
not that many people running around
talking about how great Captain America
one was
or how great Iron Man 3 was whichever
phase that even came out like there were
dud projects in the first phases
even Thor wasn't receiving yeah the
first Thor a lot of people talk about
how terrible it was and how Chris
Hemsworth didn't look like Thor and and
all these different things like the
problem is when we think phase four
compared to the rest of Marvel the rest
of Marvel and everybody's mind is end
game
but I would still say it's better than
this one or no phase one would be better
but here but also the thing is I
actually didn't think phase four was
terrible I think it had terrible
projects in it and I think it had not so
terrible but not really good projects in
it
but I mean we got Loki One Division
Chung Chi like there were so many there
were like Moon night they were good
projects so I don't want to let the few
Duds offset the entire phase that's
exactly I haven't said that right but
having said that I I do think phase five
is going to be much better I actually am
more excited about the projects and the
characters there are a lot of projects
coming yeah and I was excited about Miss
Marvel and She-Hulk oh like really
excited but I think the writing was
terrible like I actually think Miss
Marvel started off well and then towards
the end the writing just was bad got
lost we talked about this right it got
lost I thought it started off really
great and I love both characters I do
and the actors that play them but I
think with phase five just the move like
Guardians of Galaxy 3 I'm in the Lost
coin to Mania secret invasion you know
Thunderbolts is and then it ends with
the new Captain America and in between
it's like Loki I I think the projects
are genuinely better
right they're more exciting they're they
are a lot more exciting and I think
they're going to hold more importance
because we've we've already phase four
really did Lay the groundwork like with
the Rings and Miss Marvel's Bengal I'm
like we're gonna see that all come
together now they're clearly all
products of King right yeah so
we're about to see all that come
together so I think
personally face five is going to be
better I think fans are going to
actually enjoy it more I hope Wendy what
do you think I I just uh
to exercise my own caution and not to go
in with any sort of head Cannon because
I think that's one of the biggest
problems sometimes people have in myself
included have like fall victim to my own
headcanon going in like oh wouldn't it
be so great if they did XYZ and they
come out of the theater and because I'm
not the one writing the movie none of
that happened even though like in my
head Canon makes sense and you're like
oh Poo was disappointing but I think
there were some Madness
so I think with phase four it sets it's
almost like that stepping stone for us
to for them to set it all up and then
when we get to either the end of phase
five or even the beginning of phase six
they can look back and go oh they
established this back then and that's
what's so cool about them building out
this Marvel Universe and like you guys
already addressed not every single
project is going to be spectacular
you're going to like some you're not
going to like some and that's okay
because they still took the time to
establish these characters whether it's
in a Disney plus series or in a film so
I do think the stakes are a little bit
higher for phase five because of the
introduction of even though we already
kind of in a way have been introduced to
a version of Kang but
um this is going to have higher Stakes
this is going to be bigger but I don't
think we're quite at that like Infinity
war end game level yeah not not this no
we'll get there we're building up to it
that's what's exciting Secret Wars right
well okay to kind of both your points
let me and I'm going to ask Chris this
first
here's an interesting question and I'm
asking everybody listening as well yeah
if phase five is also received like
phase four was
how do you think fans are going to react
to that do you think there's going to be
a lot of fans that are like I'm kind of
done with marble or do you think they'll
hold on until phase six where we get
Fantastic Four King Dynasty Secret Wars
like do you think we'll see a lot of
falloff that phase five isn't good like
with fans like if it's the same as phase
four do you think Marvel will lose fans
I I have an eternal struggle with fan
bases I love you guys I love your guys's
comments there's good and bad to
everything
that's just right it's a movie like
I'm a super fan we're all super fans you
guys are super fans but literally it's
my life just chill that's like my thing
it's like Star Wars like I can't even
talk about Star Wars because the fans
have ruined it for me like on my channel
I I won't really talk about Star Wars
because what's the point it's just so
negative and I do see through phase four
that kind of happening with Marvel fans
like we've become kind of entitled like
we're Marvel let's stick out our chest a
little bit and this was bad this was bad
this one we need to be better but right
I mean
It's Entertainment and I've enjoyed all
of it could some of it have been better
or different or more exciting maybe but
that's really my thing about the whole
fan base so I hope not the one thing
I'll say to finish off we haven't gotten
an Avengers movie and Kevin feige is so
smart about that and we're not getting
one in Phase five when that next
Avengers movie does hit it's gonna be a
big deal
yeah so you think people are gonna hold
on for the no matter what happens you
think people are holding on for a
Fantastic Four Deadpool Avenger Basics
basically I think I think they
structured it very well to kind of
indict that yeah
yeah I I have to I have to agree I feel
like we will see let's just say like if
phase five were to be received like
phase four you're gonna see a lot of you
know weird hashtags calling for people
being fired and and this and that and
and whatever but then like if phase six
because they'll stick around
and then they'll come back and hashtag
like um
[Applause]
yeah
yeah I can see people going like oh
Kevin foggy lost his touch he's getting
all dry and then you know Secret Wars
comes like Griffin fighting is a genius
he's a God we're just passionate fans
Kevin that's all right no that's what it
comes down to is yeah there's
there's passion but then there's trying
to act like you know more than Kevin
Viking and that's what I think you know
a lot of people uh
I agree because like all these Star Wars
videos too and then it's just like I
remember I did
it was like why Darth Vader didn't kill
Obi-Wan Kenobi right away in the Kenobi
series and all the comments were like
because they had to do more episodes
it's like obviously
like oh my gosh I'm speaking inside of
this universe right if you're not if you
call yourself a fan but you can't put
yourself inside of a universe you're a
bad fan I'm sorry like in front of the
video I'm putting them at the front of
the Batman you're passionate man yeah
you're a passionate fan you're a
passionate fan but if you can't be
engulfed in this universe that you loved
then you're a little jaded and I would I
would say what Chris had to say like
just kind of try to enjoy the ride a
little bit yeah just take each movie as
its own sit there in the theater taking
that theater experience because you know
like for the longest time remember 2020
how we couldn't even go see a movie I
know nothing came out in 2012. don't
take that for granted now that now that
movie theaters have survived that entire
2020 and we're back and we get to go and
you know scream and cheer
uh at Big moments in movie theaters like
let's Embrace that and just enjoy it big
Thanksgiving
well
so I
I think phase five is going to be better
than phase four but for people who
aren't completely sold on it I think
phase six is going to be a big I think
it's just going to be big I don't want
to say it's going to be a Redemption
because I don't think Marvel's really
fallen off I just think about the pure
quantity that Marvel put out there was
bound to be some Duds like that's just
you know no one's that successful like
really and they did try to appeal to
many different
you know demographics which is cool
which is really cool so everything's not
going to be I remember texting Wendy
when I'm like did you like that episode
of She-Hulk and she's like yeah I'm the
key demographic I'm like yeah oh it was
the wedding episode yeah yeah
I was like cool and but I could sit
through She-Hulk and watch it
and be fine
did I like love it no
am I hating it and turning against
Marvel no oh what I mean
I'm out that's it Marble's done it's
thin yeah I'm done because one show
right I mean but I could sit there but
you have to realize like I realized like
it's not made for me but I can sit there
and watch it I will I won't re-watch it
I won't
I'll rewatch midnight I really like no I
was trying to think like as like a 26
year old male like Miss Marvel wasn't
made for me She-Hulk wasn't really made
for me right you know like there are
different points and and I still enjoyed
them I still had fun would I have gone a
different direction that's the thing
sure but you're not so jaded to where
you're like screw Marvel no because
there are really awesome aspects like
for example what I took out of Miss
Marvel
is how cool is it that the world lives
in a world where superheroes and aliens
and evil villains exist like you're
looking at these high schoolers right
it's kind of and there's like oh who's
your favorite superhero like imagine if
we had superheroes on earth like yeah
what what would there be freaking
athletes yeah exactly but you know how
cool K-Pop Stars
that's what I took out of Miss Marvel so
you have to be able to find those
details that apply to you yeah and now
moving into any of these future movies
and projects and shows that are coming
out like we live in a world where people
could find sunken alien treasure in the
ocean like go go find it I want a series
just on that let's go right or
yeah
or you know hey there's a giant
Celestial sticking out of the water now
yes uh if that was on Earth I'd be on
the top of it already you know like oh
for sure we would be there I'd be
climbing the tourist destination yeah
pretty much like what do you mean a
giant alien that created the planet is
actually there okay let's uh yeah
um but phase five I'm really excited for
I am and even
if I take a look at the phase four slate
in the phase five slate I can compare
them side to side and be like yeah I'm
more excited for baseball
like just the projects in the carriage
that we have coming and then you then
like phase four really did set up a lot
so phase five is going to address that
and then it's all going to really come
to fruition in phase six so
for the people that enjoy phase four I
would say hold on and enjoy the ride
like above all else enjoy the ride and
then I think even if you're not like
totally sold with phase five Basics
we'll get you
that's right and if not phase six phase
seven
phase seven with the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four and Chuck Norris what
Chuck Norris
saved him to you
well I mean if we got Harrison Ford wait
is Chuck Norris still alive
yeah
okay I don't think you could ever he's
okay he's okay
so I don't know I I think
I think a lot of fans are gonna see like
a pretty big I'll just say it like
Redemption Arc in Phase five what do
y'all think no I think the projects are
there the hype should be there and
they'll still be people complaining
about this project I don't care about or
that or the other but
it's all leading to an end game a
different to end the game and
we could just go away like well then
I'll we just spent the first 25 minutes
of this podcast complaining about how
Justice League was the first project of
the DC EU and now we're sitting here
saying like trying to convince the
Marvel fans that secret Wars shouldn't
have been the first project of phase
four like it's the same story like just
it'll show up yeah I'll ask this
question to end it
I know my answer do you think Secret
Wars will be better than endgame
oh I can't say way too much
way too early for that
I think it has to be I think it's gonna
be bigger I don't think it has an option
but to be
but will it be
well let's say half the rumors are true
and the likes a lot of original X-Men
show up
Toby and Andrew show up again uh you
know Fantastic Four will be there and
maybe some variants like John Krasinski
returns like you know stuff like that uh
Eternal Celestia like you know who knows
what it could be but I think the
potential is definitely there oh
potential is 100 there the potentials
there for sure go make it happen if they
pull it off it would be better but they
have to pull it off well obviously but I
do think it is kind of Paramount that it
is bigger for sure
I feel like it is going to be bigger but
will it be better
I'm trying to think back to
you know those moments in end game and
where you're you're cheering and crying
but like at the same time because
they took the time it was like what 22
movies before we got to end game right
right exactly we had all this time to
connect to these characters and that's
why I think
that's why I don't think phase four was
bad I think they they took the time to
let us say goodbye to some characters
and then they introduced some new
characters and there was just it's a
stepping stone and we but we need that
we need that to have those same emotions
that we felt in in-game in secret War so
it's it's not like the cameos the X-Men
and the Fantastic Fours and all this
very like that's
great but but are you excited simply
there just for a two second Cameo or
you're gonna be excited because you got
so invested in all these characters and
what they mean to the story emotionally
for them to make an impact and not just
to show up to be just to show up very
true which is why phase four is 100
necessary everything they did was 100
necessary even if you didn't really like
it yeah
we should revisit this podcast like this
this episode
ourselves
that's not like narcissistic egotistical
at all no that's just that's just trying
to make content yeah
we react to our reaction
yeah I I think we'll look back and just
be like like you said one day like
everything was so relevant
even if I didn't like it I'm glad I
watched it
so I and for those I've seen I'm not
watching this I'm not what okay
hahaha
actually a lot of people loved one if I
get so many comments did you not like it
I was not no why
Wendy's a little heart she's like it's
what it is I just don't care what if it
would be so much better what if it's the
dumbest question in the history of
questions who cares what if it's what it
is no I wasn't a fan oh I'm an I am on
my what if Island by myself well that's
no that's fine I I always tell people
you like something I don't like I'm not
giving you crap I just personally wrong
and you should feel bad
yeah no I I I just thought it was like
the biggest waste of time
granted it was three o'clock in the
morning and we're sitting there watching
it live so that didn't help that is true
problem well we're sitting there like
I'm awake for this
and it's I'm kind of a hypocrite here
because I'm sitting there to go and
enjoy the ride but I couldn't enjoy
but I literally would sit there and be
like
hey and I'll tell you what
I want to ask you this since you didn't
like it let's say you didn't watch what
if at all but then you went and watched
um any different
yeah but then you watched mom and then
they revealed that that who who Captain
Carter was like would that have made
less or more of an impact or just
wouldn't have changed anything at all
zero I'm familiar with the character I
mean
so we've been talking about rumors of
her showing up forever and I think her
showing up in a cartoon character outfit
was
demeaning because it's a character that
deserves to be in a big movie
well I I also think like if if you don't
know who
Captain Carter is you're probably also
not watching what if
also true so I think you would or you
may not read the comments because it's
not like one of the marquisitions you
were earlier talking about like the
general audience like they're not
everybody's not like us and everybody
who's watching this podcast we're
listening to this podcast that like eat
live breathe comic book characters right
exactly yeah
well
I I don't know it it probably wasn't as
bad as I'm making it out to be but I
just uh you didn't even like the zombie
episode oh wait that's not yours
I enjoyed that one a lot that's the one
I was like okay I like I actually liked
a couple of the episodes there were a
few that were just dumb Guardians of the
Galaxy one was pretty cool the zombie
one was pretty cool but overall if they
say we're canceling what if season two
and three because we're oversaturated
and we're not doing it
I wouldn't even blink I'd be like I
don't even think I'd make a video about
it
cheer
like videos of me going sorry everybody
[Laughter]
um
I'm actually really happy when people
like things that I don't like because I
feel like I wish
because I wish I could like everything
but I gotta be real right which is
ironic because a lot of people are like
you like everything like not really I
just love Thor 11th
I don't care what anybody says I like
that movie I like what you like that's
it exactly yeah it's your time and you
know yeah
yeah
so
I I look at the phase five slate and I
just think I'm gonna like everything
though if they do it right I think it's
set up to be really good
and agreed I just hope they throw
Spider-Man in the middle of it
there they're gonna have to I feel
because that's because I feel like
that's what one thing we're really
missing is like
the guy
well I I feel like there's just no
option to to have him out of it like it
doesn't make any sense especially with
uh only home being such a big Multiverse
move and everything that they're trying
to like accomplish but that's I would
argue you know a recent leak I'm sure
you both saw of the new Avengers team
moving forward
I do feel like we are missing a couple
Heavy Hitters not necessarily power wise
it it does seem like you know what I
mean a little lackluster just total
there are some big projects coming out
Thunderbolts gonna be huge new Captain
America hopefully they absolutely crush
it and I hope they do you know and all
these different things I'm stoked for
Loki season two but like Loki is an Iron
Man the Thunderbolts aren't The Avengers
we are gonna be missing that a little
bit and I think we're getting there in
phase six Once A Fantastic Four are in
and all the variants and I mean I would
bet a hundred million dollars that
Robert Downey Jr is probably going to
come back at least for a second at some
point in secret Wars you know and that's
gonna be epic but we through phase five
I do think that there will be a noted
missing presence
it's like we're just gonna have to get
over the Avengers
it's a breakup right it's cut it
it's it's not even it's almost like a
death
right because it's like
sometimes a breakup is really hard to
think positively of the person you dated
yeah
it's like kind of like a death you miss
them right and it's like oh you think
about all the good times yeah I guess I
wish they were I mean it was a literal
death for some of those characters as
well you know yeah that's what I'm
saying I think it's more death but I
think it's denial forward all right but
I think moving forward the Avengers like
in Phase seven aren't going to be as
prominent I think it's gonna be all
about the X-Men and Fantastic Four and
that's coming phase six baby
yeah so
I think it's going to be a and I think
that keeps it fresh oh I don't disagree
you know I think it keeps prayer so I
think Secret Wars King Dynasty and
Secret Wars are going to be like a big
Avengers thing and then it's gonna be
like all right we're gonna
kind of say goodbye for a little bit
they're still gonna be there
right because there'll be another
Avengers film at the end of the next
Saga but it's gonna be really about the
X-Men of the Fantastic Four which I'm
excited for because it's going to be
fresh it's going to be new and I want to
see how they mix it into our universe
were they there the whole time did the
incursions cause you know does the MCU
end up being two different universes
combined into one at the end of all this
who knows I'm really excited for them I
am really excited for it so it's
superheroes what's not to be excited
about we should just enjoy it unless
it's what if but we should enjoy it all
talk about that Mario Universe
I'm going to the Mario universe that's
it I'm out that is for uh that is for
another podcast for sure because I I do
want to talk about that because uh I'm
excited for them we know Chris Chris
Pratt is it doesn't sound Italian at all
but I'm okay with it
it's me it's me Mario
so I will leave the audience with the
question
will Secret Wars be better than any game
we've answered
I think we all agree
did we
kind of gave us
yes it's set up to be
it's set up to be bigger will it who
knows they have to do it right so all
right just we'll end with this but gut
feeling will it be better or not when do
you go
now that's not fair I'm not answering
yeah I don't know
it has the potential to be
but that's what I said
I can't I'm gonna say the opposite of
whatever Wendy says
good feeling I'll just go yes no good
feeling yes it's better than me
I say no I say no not because it's not
going to be good but I'm gonna hate
comments for this but probably just
because we haven't we haven't seen
anything even in Phase five yet so it's
really hard to imagine but do I trust in
Marvel to like do a kick-ass job she
doesn't understand yes or no questions
[Laughter]
um
yeah
we haven't been let down no not yet or
no
um
yeah and Kevin feige we trust you know
at the end of the day I haven't truly
been disappointed a project here or
there but in the mass story line of it I
have no reason to doubt otherwise
really
because back to the whatever it would
have didn't really mean anything so I
wasn't like that's why
it is a meme now I say I hate it I
didn't actually hate it it's just it's
just a meme at this point because
everyone's like yeah Warren hated what
if I'm like yeah they're doing a little
raging during this year
it's 3am I have to watch this but but um
I didn't you know you If She Hulk
which is is very low for me I was still
there watching it just kind of like it
was kind of cool like
I'm not super
disappointed with anything I think
overall phase four was great I think
phase five is only going to get better
and phase six is going to be better than
both of them and Secret Wars will be
better than in-game I said I mean I hope
so that that's I want just like up and
up and up you know
yeah what I want
yep hopefully but hey let us know your
thoughts down below if you are still
here watching thank you you made it and
then we thought we were gonna be here
today
I don't know on Chris's screen this way
or Wendy's
no Wendy's under you
good check out nope other way
go check out Chris that's me on his
channel and then go check out Wendy you
did it
her Channel yeah we'll put the links
down below and uh we'll catch you on the
next podcast